[Applause]
[Music]
for example in Portland Oregon it's
illegal for your dreadlocks to get
caught in your unicycle spokes yes law
in Texas too much yappin can result in a
fine of up to 200 now gets in Reno
Nevada you will be fined $500 for making
any positive life choices in Iowa
corn-fed beef must be raised on a diet
of beef fed corn in West Dakota it is
illegal to inform residents that there
is no such state as West Dakota you just
keep on paying them West Dakota taxes
in Bayonne New Jersey it's illegal to
mix up a one a tease with one of those
in Gary Indiana when a man named Gary
hooks up with a woman named Diana that
sounds people must refer to them as Gary
in Diana in Tuttle Oklahoma it is
illegal to brag about the many many
fascinating things for which the city is
known just is
in Rhode Island if anyone asks where
you're from you might just want to say
New England and leave it at that
in Oahu Hawaii it is a felony to park
you your aha punana within 50 feet of a
neighbor's Hanukkah honey lani unless
you have a permit from the Department of
Kalikimaka Howie opala
Maui namah hi
[Music]
I'd like a rum drink yeah man I'm so
glad I didn't get that one and finally
in Boston Massachusetts when ordering a
cup of tea you must pronounce it a cup
of coffee for [ __ ]
[Applause]
you